الاحتجاجات التي لم تخلو من اعتقالات
ومواجهه مع الشرطه بعد تخليها عن
استراتيجيه ضبط النفس الاسبوع الماضي تاخذ
الان منعطفه جديده لا سيما مع الدعوه الى
عصيان الاوامر العسكريه بين ضباط وجنود من
الجيش الاسرائيلي معظمهم من الاستخبارات
العسكريه والسلاح الجو وقوات النخبه
والمدفعيه دقه نقوص الخطر الحقيقي بعد ان
اعلن هؤلاء عزمهم عدم المشاركه في تدريبات
كانت مقرره لهم سبعه وثلاثون طيارا
احتياطيا اسرائيليا من اصل اربعين يعتزمون
عدم الحضور لتدريبات مقرره الاربعاء
المقبل والقلق يتصاعد من ظاهره رفض الخدمه
العسكريه التي تطورت وبلغت ابعاد مطلقه
بحسب رئيس الاركان هيرسي هاليدي وهو الذي
حذر نتنياهو من ان هذا العصيان سيضر
بقدرات الجيش العمليه وتسرب
المكالمه بينهما كان مطلقا ايضا وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي يعاف جلند حليفونه نياهو
دعا الى حل الازمه ببدء مفاوضات بين معسكر
المعارضه والائتلاف حول القانون المثير
للجدل الذي يسعى نتنياهو الى تمريره وفجر
التظاهرات في الشارع منذ مطلعي يناير
[موسيقى]